hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here with Wade and Bob say hi guys
alright hi hello everybody I've been
having some trouble getting this started
but we are back in it to win it with our
newest project of epic proportions hi
Bob why do you have to Indy huh oh you
did you didn't see anything okay alright
highway but hey how you doing today I'm
good
look good it was good that I can
actually see you now yeah so anyway what
we're gonna be building here is we want
to make an homage to our favorite
colorful character a favorite kaboom
kaboom know our favorite colorful
character grizzly the bear noogie the
bear is business monkey the grizzly bear
he's a grocer remember everybody only
you can prevent forest fires so we've
been actually having some trouble so
we've been drinking a while and Wade's
jumping the gun but while he's getting
started I am drinking out of my awesome
Batman pimp cup here which is a
half-filled now with an amaretto sour
and I swear I dropped a half a bottle of
Disaronno in here and it is like the
tastiest drink I've ever had in my life
but as I said before we've been having
some trouble so why what are you guys
doing down there
I'm from anyway from starting to early
haha wait can do whatever he wants okay
what are you guys drinking hi
I was drinking beer I don't know what
that bottle went now it's empty so now
I'm drinking this which is huh it looks
like the manliest thing ever it's pink
crystal light with energy and vodka
hahahahaha so you just to put vodka in
the glass and then poured cause I think
energy drink with vodka I like it I like
it a lot vodka vodka okay alright so
rage vodka so what we're doing here is
we're building a smokey the grizzly bear
and he has bare feet and he has pants
and hey wait guys are we allowed to have
bear arms
huh I don't think so I think that's
against the Constitution now or
something no politics in my drunk Micra
ah build your dam barely daddy your
weight your mess with my bare foot yours
wasn't thick enough look now they met
one of these has time you guys got the
feet I'm gonna go build a bow tie over
here we all know what happened last time
Wade built feet
ha ha ha ha ha no it was the legs that
were bad oh it was the feet hey wait
that's how high you wanted the leg to be
right yeah I got it I went you cuz Wade
said while we were gone or while we're
having trouble there that the legs he
was so upset at everything we've built
everything we built had short stubby
legs so we needed we needed longer legs
so you guys are making the legs come out
where the toes are supposed to be when
you're talking oh yeah ha ha ha ha ha oh
yeah I forgot this must be shaped to the
foot as you screw up everything shut up
Wade somehow this is all your fault yeah
oh oh oh you're fixing them question
quotation marks yes this is gonna take a
while God we got we history says jumping
the gun with built the legs not oh I'm
making an executive decision I'm shoring
up the legs about five blocks ok yeah
Julie I don't really save it yeah I mean
it just saves us a little extra time
really it's a style thing yeah yeah cuz
one won't 5 more blocks would it just
look silly
it looked ridiculous exactly this is
very tasteful mm yeah
that's the word that I could use to
describe everything we ever do that
would be tasteful
yeah double-spaced makes you fall and
professional right oh no yes yes I've
tried as hard as I can I'm clicks
bearing so much I'm gonna kill my mouse
oh my hand is already getting kind of
tired bugs expanding wait why'd you make
the legs so damn long you made the
haha you made this last time you guys
made thighs and all of a sudden we had
stubby little chicken slender you made
me make them you think I don't know all
right
yeah well he's got no thighs oh I don't
know why I bother answering guys are
anything that's where it connects he's
got nothing he's got nothing there well
he's only got three blocks in between
his legs in your plank ha ha ha ha she's
own vault
that's his crotch bears don't have a
crotches uhh
oh god it's so bad actually just earlier
today I saw a video of a bear playing
with his balls what's up I'll ask me how
I came across it why would you come
across it huh I think it was a gif
actually like someone posted something
that had to do with like bear porn I
don't know what we're they're building
getting deleted huh where you want our
bear horn our bear point is there a
subreddit for bear porn I hope God
please don't look it up and tell us no
this is a kid show did it is before now
there is yeah yeah well and didn't I say
that there was this was gonna be a kids
show like for kids it is a kitchen okay
but then we had to stop recording
because we lost Bob yeah Bob adds some
troubles out of them I've been with I've
been drinking for about you know what my
troubles were what or that shitty
Ethiopian Internet yeah yeah we have it
for like four hours you have a reference
that in a long time
now a season one baby season one the
season one references are going to be
coming back hot and heavy oh we really
decided I'm gonna be our of it
what's an Abed it's Abed from community
I don't watch Katie he references you
know TV shows including community itself
I just I've been told I should watch
community but I it's kind of like whose
line in a lot of ways you'd probably
find it really funny I probably would I
think I've she's the same kind of like
humor out of absolutely no inspiration
or discernible direction sort of thing
ah kind of like live-action Family Guy
and sort of a way
the family gun shot is exactly how that
goes don't even pretend to be done I'm
going to drink a lot bored out cuz I
hate do I need to catch back up our way
to drink I went out and you were like oh
man I'm not drunk enough overweight all
little egg radio us while I was waiting
for my internet to all right you got a
little legs I misheard her pants he's
worried he has great pants right I
thought how are we doing pants are there
gonna be pants on top of his leg oh yes
pants covering I stole the pants oh God
what strange we just get like a thong or
something he does have room for my body
well I guess if it's a one-block string
bikini thong I guess this would be the
type for it is there any other kind of
sideshow
well yeah there's multiple different
cardigan phone it says probably uh uh
kids if you're out there good song
hahaha
Oh reals other song yes the leather
thong who does who made this so damn
tall you know I didn't seriously this if
there's only three blocks of thong and I
already am laughing at it wait hang on I
gotta bail oh my god I gotta pull the
camera out hi god I can't forgetting
that I'm actually recording and people
are watching what I'm seeing so I got a
what is that ha ha ha why is it made out
of obsidian bedrock it'll be bad leather
thong that's not leather leather thong
it's like Flintstones leather where's
his balls playing what is tell what is
that
he's like 900 feet tall and he's a
four-block tail he's got a propeller for
a tail just whit hang on this wind we're
gonna make it a swastika on oh yeah good
show oh oh just like get well wait no I
think I missed a step here
it doesn't look right did I do something
wrong here doesn't look right Bob what
did I do wrong
if they're not long enough
hahahaha it's it's a square with just
these blocks like right here missing no
not that you dumbass swastik doing ha ha
ha ha you said it wasn't long enough not
those ones other ones ah good enough
like that ha ha ha ha Oh that way
oh ok are they gonna have brown on the
end of them that's a skis actually this
looks so disturbing it is I don't have
any of that hang on what but the one
Ford's back and then I'll dare bro yeah
that does not look good at all it's lil
wrong it looks like a submarine
propeller now alright leave it whatever
I'm done
I gotta shore up these legs cuz they're
freakin long he's a volcano why is that
he's not on fire yet that's the
super-secret end oh no you don't even
know the super secret ending what's the
super secret ending I have a super
secret ending well that's not super seat
does it have to do with my original idea
of the SNM SNM Smokey the Bear oh god
this is a doom for the star why do we
build this they'll ever come out
anything like what they're supposed well
get your head out of my phone there are
those days haha ah don't want to say to
a friend ha ha ha he has no bulge
he needs a bulge here Oh God oh wait
come on he needs like gotta give him
something all right hold on he's a bear
for God's sake yeah
proud bear what is that this is a stake
hold on
I don't have any bedrock pulled up so
I'm not even gonna touch that
I'll touch my phone without my boss
say that again louder and clearer Sauron
do you touch my thong but not my bulge
that's what I thought that it wasn't
this funny the second time although it
wasn't clear this force
okay so much nicer when it comes
willingly yeah yeah
targets don't even try wait you're not
funny okay so anyway we got um the semi
swastika tail the thong made out of
bedrock and just a moderate bullet what
is match oh my god oh oh oh my god yes
take good sick
that's gotta stay now Oh kid show
ahahaha okay all right I'm done
that's great Oh who did that I just said
you did happy I was pretty sure as Bob
oh I just turned around I was not ready
hoorah
okay anyway so now we're the one who's
complaining he didn't have a bulge and I
was just making their realistic haha
didn't finish his legs he's got these
hollow links we gotta build the torso I
mean we only have so much time where do
you start the torso look the most
offensive thing I've ever seen in my
life I why it's not more offensive than
your statue of ways well no I mean I
adds a combination of the bikini the
swastika tail and I don't know
is it pretty bad
hahahaha why where did you come up with
swastika I don't know it just popped out
of my head I've been drinking for a
while
God a delicious amaretto sour well
that'll livered win the hell losing
subscribers but we're also try to get
bad today yes
try just yourself on the losing
subscribers front quick I'm constantly
gaining subs
who's gonna ban us from the server Oh
apparent reason for the server quarters
Oh YouTube heart sings I'd watch it go
down the drain please don't want these
partnership people don't watch this at
all
oh hey way do you want to have a race oh
I guess not
okay wait wasn't the one of the tour so
supposed to be a different color um
probably not I'm pretty sure something
around okay bring a shirt well oh my
castle most disturbing vintage do not do
dock layout and look at it from a
distance because it's not getting better
what's wrong with this right oh no I
dropped my brown oh no oh no oh no you
dropped your brown what's wrong with
this leg what am i man what's wrong this
is low it's just the perspective his
legs are so deep that it's like a
hallway between them God is very
disturbing uh-oh I got a guy takin all
the majesty of what this is you can see
be using you can see far away oh I can't
believe this is haha oh beloved Smokey
the Bear what have we done to you
nothing good or appropriate it's a good
thing we're gonna burn this thing to the
ground at the end of this we should
probably holy hell this is wrong okay we
got to make the face now so uh that's a
little bit less weird now but the
swastika tail still is okay
this bedrock burners it does not just be
a floating thong in the middle oh god is
this going then I'm gonna all be
constructive here this is why this is
the face Oh
this is Wade are you ok wait
I just lost my headphones I lost my
chair Oh a very black dude I'm gonna do
what I said I was gonna do woke up with
the chicken eyes time for the Hannibal
mask on him do go sure yeah no that's
work ok oh I can't get any worse
Oh God it's gonna be look like a Bane
mask more than anything so I don't even
though
I don't even know anymore let us do this
I think they just haven't found out yet
is his head only gonna be like what
Scotia no no wait hang on don't put the
mask there bring it out some it's got it
we look like a pig
what is that what is it what is this
what is this I don't even understand ok
anyway bring this metal out like bring
it out cuz he's got have a muzzle and we
gotta have a place to put Wade yeah I
don't know he's got like you know how
animals
exhibit doing anatomically correct for
one part because wow yeah curse to be
light brown no brown brown
we can't wait brakes that oh you wanna
make it out of birch wood okay I never
it won't look good but yeah sure go
ahead
Oh awful anyway oh okay
I think the chicken eyes are a good idea
they look they look pretty good at like
I like the way those look
oh oh that's cool these did you guys see
that when I broke that kind of crossed
in the middle there ooh I like it I like
it a lot Bob where are you
nowhere nowhere what are you doing what
are you - to you down there
hi hi one hi hi she is oh oh wait where
to go oh okay all right carry on what
the who just flew under here and ruined
my mouth oh you didn't hey Mark you
wanna create a boat is destructive mark
you want see the super secret ending uh
yes we're a what oh okay huh chicken
hahaha
you like above you like ha ha oh god
I've got an addition but you're gonna
have an afro are you putting it out I'm
putting the ball gag in his mouth hey
you're yeah I am so he's got a a
Hannibal mask with a ball gag hunt yes
and that little pink Oh God oh I can't
look down ha ha ha oh alright looks like
he's wearing glasses I think we need to
destroy this now I think we need to
never speak of this ever again because
this is just there's just little
probably the worst thing we've ever made
in our entire oh my god I like that
what's the one lava I and the other
chicken I
ha ha ha remember kids only you can
prevent forest fires
we know we didn't we need to give him an
arm pointing ha ha ha ha ha ha can we
have it spiraling out like just in a
twirly pattern I'm gonna make one arm
you make another arm I've already got it
in my arm I got the arm yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
oh it's day now yeah here yeah yeah ha
oh I drink for Cara are you guys talk
for a bit I'm tired
oh hi ball how's it going weight pretty
good I'm just over here making smokey a
more efficient efficient at what please
check out the scenery what just take a
look around
smokey you know towards the ground I
don't know what you're talking about you
should it stands out quite a bit you
look at his feet oh my god there's on
fire
Oh respire smokey can't do squat oh I
got it I got it
hang on I got it um a really bad idea
burning everything ah ah this is so bad
shut up
what is that are you getting in the
middle finger yeah only you can prevent
it ha ha ha ok I can totally make up for
it what is that it's gotta be a cannon
really what is it gonna shoot me
hahahahahaha I wish I wish it so many
ways that we could be gocator they could
actually shoot people ha ha ha I'm just
taking in the Majesty that is this our
smokey the bear has the entire forest
around us burns to ash obviously a show
we were all lucky enough to know smoking
very very well in the press ship really
that's gone into this thing uh uh you
know what this reminds me of ever my
dearly how could this remind you no no
it really does Bob you went to four
channel a while ago you know you know
when they would give some they would
give a thread like they would start out
with something like a blank sheet and
it's Li like fill in the blanks and he'd
be like from A to B solve this problem
and then they would draw these random
things in the middle of it this seems
like something that would come out of
the creativity of that mind like I swear
it's it with this this would fit exactly
into that like in no way I had such high
hopes when we had bare falls four feet
what are not so good haha well I mean is
that I got groin what you you you wanted
the legs to be longer so they're all
okay until we get to the groin it always
oh my god I'm going to set this on a
path to destruction all right cannon
finished good cannon I'm going to start
placing TNT everywhere because this I'm
I am so way ahead of you mark you have
no idea really literally have not even
the slightest idea can you do something
if you got a big finale finished just
about can you send this thing off to
it's a primary thing start to catch on
fire really quick and I'll set this off
so you want me to let it on fire yeah
let everything on fire let's get this
really cooking
haha alright because this this this this
is why you shouldn't drink everybody
ladies and gentleman know this is a
prime example can't believe I'm doing
this mark are you at the front
no I'm about to be alright I'm at the
front now what ooh something wait why'd
you lie the penis on fire it had to go
I suppose so alright things are burning
at a pretty good pace there but it's
on yeah it's going alright let's see how
this works oh my god here okay um oh oh
oh my god everything's lagging oh my
gosh sorry Bob oh my god oh yeah okay
I'm so on
I still it Oh
dynamite that you have in there oh I
spent most of that entire episode after
I'm the penis hauling out underneath him
and filling it with dynamite it's still
blowing up I got nothing done by street
here its eyeball is leaking lava see it
ha ha oh it's so bad those let's never
build anything ever again because I mean
at first news I at first it was really
kind of funny and then it got really
really scary really quickly why you
point out that it got scary when you and
Bob got to the groin ha ha ha
well I'll give you that but at least I
still have no frame rain who's still
like totally god I'm like really great
30 pounds I think zombie was building
something in that cannon I think I saw
like a rail to shoot somewhat out there
I thought just got blown to [ __ ] oh my
god or maybe it's still there I don't
know I think the Kate is still there ah
I got endless cuz I got no frames here
fine it'll come back
that's when zombie who wins zombie yeah
who wins yeah let's see how long it
takes ready to type something into this
I can't even get my type box to come up
build the chat off smart whatever you
know what I'm talk--i
ha ha i'ma put a little bit too much
dynamite if I'm gonna be honest about it
haha yeah I think so I think that was
over
kill mm-hmm well let's see who the
winner is if for subterfuge but total
backfire Bob gets all this I think
that's pretty appropriate way to go Bob
you crashes I'll be server
I bet everyone else on the other server
is like whoa what the hell is happening
what I can't move what
oh my Josh try like a slack malware
zombie lives like just all the powers
just going down oh okay
all right let's end this horrible
episode this is the worst episode of any
season that's so bad I don't know it was
one where we built a house yeah that was
pretty badly really some people thought
that was like so dad never mind anyway
so why don't we get worse over time I
don't know how we do it well let's just
everybody who've watched this forget
this ever happened
don't drink it's bad for you so thriller
over you can prevent forest fires
this should wait thank you all so much
for watching I guess um this been
waiting Bob so Bob has lost so say bye
guys I guess see you guys later I guess
hi I guess so this ever lows will record
some more who in the next thing bye
Oh
Oh
bud
you know I'm